so good to see you because the last time
you and i chatted was on a zoom call oh
my god yeah what was it wild mountain
time
so how are you how's everything going
good yeah yeah family's good yeah
family's great i think like everyone
else we're just trying to
muddle through you know and and
we're presented with so many different
challenges in the last yeah year and a
half and we're all just trying to ride
it out and come out the other side and
hope that we've got our heads intact and
we haven't you know let anyone die and
you know we're we're still heading the
right direction it's been a brutal um
time for lots of reasons for and for
lots of people so
um it's nice to be standing here
with people and have that human you know
i think that's a big
takeaway from
in the telluride last week and tiff this
week that sort of um yeah
reconnection almost with people you know
and uh
jesus that's so important you know so um
it's nice to be back here yeah and it's
this film is such a sincere film to
belfast and working with kenneth i
understand it's a full circle for you
that you saw you had your dad used to
have a photo of him right right
like that's kind of insane to think
about it was crazy yeah well also i'm
one of those people like i'm from there
so
people from belfast know that ken's from
belfast but a lot of people don't you
know it's one of those weird things
where because he end up having this very
um grandiose uh often shakespearean
career and he's got a science like posh
english dude yeah and people don't
realize he's from a working class area
in belfast so
it's um but i knew you know and everyone
from home knows and we're all very proud
of it and uh
yeah there's a picture on our uh
um
bookshelf
crazy and ken uh opening uh a wing at
the maternity ward at the hospital my
dad spent majority of his career at so
yeah i remember thinking you know sort
of you know was a big thing in the house
like yeah that he had been around and
done that and met dad and stuff so yeah
it's nice to dad must be really proud
yeah
yeah and kenneth got you dancing you got
you kind of singing
i mean that was impressive did you enjoy
that part of it all yeah yeah to a point
i i do enjoy it it's it's it's it's
terror like uh
that you can't even imagine i don't even
know i'm sure people you know heading
into war or something are more terrified
but it's it's it's rough
um just
it's like an extra thing that you're
having to worry about to think about i
sort of you know
with the um
the song it's my vocals but also the
vocals of
um of love affair as well so i'm sort of
bolstered by that and not totally
exposed by myself
i've sang in a lot of things recently i
think the last four or five things i've
done i've sang in and um it's time for
this it's becoming to have it habitual
i'm slightly worried about it that i i
don't remember how to just do straight
acting and i'm always singing but
yeah it's a nice thing to express yeah
and it's a reflection of joy and
troubled times right absolutely true
yeah and um you know seeing it through
your young boy's eyes and this sort of
heightened sense of everything that's
going on and and uh
you know we're good at that in ireland
we're good at celebration of life you
know and we we bury people pretty quick
we usually usually out a week within you
know three days of uh someone dying and
but it ends up being a celebration it
often ends up being a sing song you know
that's kind of the way we are and i
wouldn't change for the world really so
what is your joy
my kids yeah that's just the easiest
answer ever you know i'm
so lucky that i've i have three healthy
little girls and
i'm
just missing them so much actually this
week
i haven't this is uh i've been away from
them for two years like most people so
um
i'm excited to i'm excited to be here
don't get me wrong but i'm excited to
get home to my wife and my kids well
thank you for this film it's an
absolutely gorgeous